Megan and she will talk about sparse
graph limits
we're the organized
organized
together is such a wonderful word for
Workshop I literally enjoyed every
moment of it and part of me wish that
the workshop could be longer
it's a real pity that Sophia could not
make it she and I were flatmates during
a long workshop at the Newton Institute
in Cambridge many years ago and she
taught me how to speak like a real
mathematician for example instead of
saying I haven't made up my mind yet a
better way to put that would be my mind
hasn't converged yet now many vegetable
stories from her
um so I've been working on dense random
graphs for more than 10 years and have
made friends and met collaborators along
the way coincidentally the first
conference told I gave on this subject
was at your random in 2011 and I
remember ramco was a scientific director
and after my thought he asked me so do
you have any results for sparse for us
yeah so embarrassing me at that moment
my understanding of spacecrafts was very
naive and my spice is the result was
um an ergo model of putting a graph
whose Edge density goes to zero but it's
still in the n-square limit Ram toy
might not know this but your question
start with me everything and today I'm
going to give my first conference talk
on spacecraft
it's a continuing learning process for
me and I'm excited to share with people
what I've known so far so
um before it starts graphs various sales
graphs so I'm going to summarize the
dense graph theory in a couple slides
um so
like starting point for learning about
all those graph models I would say Low
by sport on large graphs and also Ram
close to volume but one was already
published I didn't put 2022 plus because
I saw on a website you said it's 2023
and I believe
yeah okay and then
all this way sure so for a graphical
space we've seen many times by now uh
it's a function from the unit Square to
the unit interval and then the function
value denotes the probability of Putting
Edge between the two vertices so people
have studied this dense graph Theory
from different perspectives and then
there are different ways to characterize
convergence there is less convergence
right conversions metric conversions
convergence of quotients Etc in
particular left convergence and cut
metric convergence are more or less the
same and then the other convergence are
also equivalent
under the condition of compartments so
you might remember that for classical uh
dense graph regime the function is from
the unit Square to the unit interval
there is nothing special about this
being a unit Square except that it's
compact so under this compactness regime
there are lots of nice results showing
convergence and the low are ldp and then
um yeah over the years people have had
many results and strategy and diatomies
were the among the first people to put a
rigorous theory on dense graph limits in
Oregon and then England audience
Hollander and Charles Rayden also had a
number of papers from the statistical
physics perspective and then in the
statistics
right so yeah this is just like a
picture showing the view of dense graph
limits
and then in the statistics Community
people have studied limiting graphs from
a variety of perspectives
and many people here in audience are
experts at all these convergence result
and also application simulation and many
things so I will first give a survey on
the sparse graph limits and my survey
will mainly be based on the results in
which Android and also in both Chase
call and holder
um
okay so to go from Spa scrap the dense
graphs to den of spice graphs there are
different approaches you can take so the
approach I'm going to talk about today
is going from array to measure so
um
as have been mentioned in the past days
for dense graphs
the theory
uh relies on exchangeability result from
Alderson Hoover in the 1979 through 1981
and then
um at that time when we were talking
about exchangeability it's for a race
but if we extend it to more generally to
measure it there is calendar Bird's
representation theorem and then
um
I'm going to expand on that in the next
few slides but also please let me note
that this past ref limit Theory
um in this setting will cover a wide
class of spice graphs but also not all
possible starts graphs for example
um the barabasi Albert preferential
attachment model and also the model
distressed by loots on Wednesday and not
covered under the series because we do
need a certain sense of exchangeability
for this Theory to work
um okay so this is
um callenberg's representation theorem
in a nutshell so uh for draft Farm we
just have a function from the main unit
Square to the unit interval and then
more generally there is something called
Graphics the graphics has three
components one is a graph fund component
and when the star component and Y is the
dust component and the test component
consists of isolating edges but still
the graphics component is a major
component and the idea is that instead
of restricting ourselves from the unit
Square to the unit interval we can
do from R plus Square to the unit
interval or even more generally from R
plus Square to R and then the S part the
star our part will be an integrable
function and then the dust part will
consists of isolating edges so all these
three components will be driven by
independent personal processes
and for typical realization
we can take s equals W equals zero and
then still just to think about the
graphics part
and also we can generalize even more
from R plus squared even further to
Sigma finite measure space and the
result will follow through so
um how do we visualize this when we are
given a graphics W my idea is that we
will first run a personalization
argument and then we put points down on
R plus 12 and the points will follow
um
and typically there will be infinitely
many points there and then we connect
the points see the I comma C the J with
probability PW comma
um
Nui new J and then
um s and I should be now zero the
respectively correspond to let's start
an isolation actually like I just
mentioned and then
um to model a growing graph typically
people would also do some time cut and
then let the model grow a world high so
this is a super simple illustration of
what is going on so the idea is that we
would put down points following a unit
rate person process so here I just put
down two points but in general there'll
be many many points and then say I look
at this point and at this point I would
connect the cedar values of these two
points so this point at this point
becomes this point and this point here I
will connect Theta values of these
points by their corresponding value in W
of Nu I nu J so we see that here the Nui
value is equal to this and the new J
value is equal to this
and again this is just a simple
illustration of what is going on in
general like you will if you do a Time
cut then you will have infinitely many
vertices and finitely many connected
edges in the space
um
so the main takeaway for this fast graph
limit scenery is that when we do not
have compact support
many interesting phenomena could happen
and then
um
also when we have compact support then
that
different
like the different vertices
um given those variables they are
independent but now the latent variables
associated with the vertex and not
independent anymore once the support is
not Compact and
um so the space of probability
distributions on dense graph can be
parametrized by graph funds and then the
space of probability distribution of
sparse graph can be parametrized by
graphics and thank you to Peter Robbins
for a very informative talk on Tuesday
and help clarifying A lot of confusing
points on quadratic Theory so for the
graph on dense graph on Space the
extremal points are precise they are the
extremal points of that garlic Theory
and then for sparse graphs the graphic
seeds are precisely the extremo points
and all other probability measures will
become a mixture of those
all right so
um
I just want to make sure I understand
the definition so by for an example
suppose I construct a random geometric
graph in the following way
so I'm going to reveal a larger and
larger region around the origin in R2
say
or R if you prefer and then I I have
points that are generated by a poisson
process with uh some fixed density and
then I connect two points uh if the
distance between them is lesser than or
equal to one so some people call this
the unit disk model yeah and so as it
grows you know everybody has a constant
average degree and so on
so is this a graphics where the function
W is sort of large on the diagonal
where you know we connect things if
they're you know it's it's one within a
certain band because that's how if
they're and zero outside that
or is this not a graphics or
um I mean typically for dense graphs I
mean for dense Graphics the convention
is to take the diagonal to be zero
and then for graphics like
um the convention is to take the
diagonal to be zero but there are
definitely generalizations so as long as
it's a function from R plus Square to
zero one that's considered to be a
graphics but like depending on what w
looks like there will be different
properties derived
okay well I I guess I got W rung I mean
I
I think your W is defined on let's say
just
I think you got it right so if you
actually would you you can think sort of
or let's say it's on R okay then you can
think of the position in rsf feature and
two vertices in W is is a function on R
cross r
and it's non-zero around the diagonal
maybe adds a diagonal it's zero but then
in a band of widths
your radius it's non-zero and that would
be an example which fits her stuff and
if I want to do this on R2 I have to do
the the usual crazy yes uh continuous or
you can do it on R22
thank you
but it's not integrable so it doesn't
fit into this Theory right because the
diagonal extends to Infinity that's a
very good question I'm going to talk
about
right okay so in Christian's paper they
assumed the graphics to be integrable
but later today we will see that we can
extend this year in some sense
all right so uh for graphics or like
just the graph from part of the graphics
there are different Notions of matric
there is that cut metric for dense
graphs and then because right now we are
talking about sparse graphs so there are
potentially different ways to generalize
a metric one is called the reselled
cartometric well you resale the height
of the function and there is also
stretch cut metric where you stretch the
domain of the function and also there
are many other metrics so I'm going to
show a picture illustration of what's
going on so this is a graphene and in
the cut metric the standard cut my trip
and this is reselled cut metric well I'm
going to just stretch the height of the
function and there is also
uh stretch and I said well I'm
stretching the domain of the function
okay but are you assuming that the
domain remains compact
um I mean so it's just a picture
illustration so like my domain will not
be compact just showing like to consider
right so uh I'm particularly interested
in the rescaled and stretched the
pathometric because of the example I'm
going to present today and we are going
to see that under certain conditions it
will be uh
resale metric and then if we change the
model a bit certainly we are in the
stretched cut metric region
but for the the cut metric if your space
is normally compact
right right so we are just talking about
dense graph I'm saying that this is a
step
um I felt like so far I've been
borrowing from Christian and various
people's work you know so
um now finally I'm going to tell you
something about my own work okay
um so I'm going to use a toy example to
Showcase various interesting things
about space grass
and we will cast it in the graph phone
limit Theory framework and also see some
other interesting phenomena so
I got into this model from reading a
paper from Christian and there he
presented a motivating example for power
law graph to study LP graph conversions
and I was like okay this model is
interesting what if we twist the model a
bit what will we get so let's first look
at their model the model is that if we
have n vertices numbered once to n and
then we connect vertices IJ with this
probability
so essentially what we are doing is that
we connect the different vertex labels I
mean IJ with
connection probability IJ to the power
negative key one over Alpha and then we
are going to
boost it by a factorial of n to the beta
in case the connection probability
becomes too small
and uh sorry I should also mention that
they studied this model in the parameter
regime where Alpha is greater than 1 and
beta is in between 0 and the two over
Alpha
that means that the the average degree
grows like a positive power of n right
exactly so the average degree for their
model
so it draws like and to uh I mean yeah
the edge density grows like this and the
average degree grows like
um to the power and like the key one or
whatever
and then they found out that in the
rescaled cut metric the limiting graph
file looks like this and then this
limiting grapher is in LP for NEP less
than Alpha
uh this is their model and uh I was
thinking okay what if we change the
model a little bit so we still have M
vertices numbered one through n and then
we connect vertices IJ with this
probability okay
okay so you can see that right now it's
a deterministic probability not the
probability they have here so their
probability is like if this value is
greater than one definitely
deterministically we connect two
vertices if the value is less than one
then we connect it with certain
probabilities less than one so there's
some Randomness there and then for my
model here it's like if the
product here it's greater than when we
still connect them and if the product is
less than one we just don't connect them
at all so our graph will be faster than
their graph and their graph is already
expired so this graph will be even
faster and then I also reformulate
reformulated the notations a little bit
but you can see the resemblance here so
I will still have a normalization
constant here and then you might
remember in their model
is I over n to this power and J variant
to this power so instead of having Iran
joran I just say it's an IID uniform
zeroy random variable so I continualized
the setting a bit and then still power
another key one over Alpha but the major
difference is that I dropped all the
soft so-called soft edges
um
okay so uh for this model and also I
should mention that for their model the
parameter regime they are interested in
using this parameter regime for the uh
for the adapted model I will study the
model uh in every parameter regime so in
particular there is a so-called
cryptical regime and this critical
regime can be reformulated as a
personalization Point process
convergence and it was studied in this
paper
so actually they studied
um
parameter very large but then under some
formulation it can become parameter very
small
and then in this talk I'm going to
concentrate on the model away from
criticality and as we will soon see uh
there will be a sub-critical regime and
silver critical regime and a
supercritical regime will correspond to
the parameter regime in Christian's
paper
all right so and yeah I just uh
of what happened between their model and
my model so the first thing is that
um we did a continualization of the
vertex labels that's of minor
technicality and the major thing is that
we dropped many more edges and also like
for the parameter regime they studied in
our paper in their paper it would become
the super critical thinking so beta
greater than zero will become am
lesson and to the power to over Alpha
and the interesting thing is that by
dropping all those edges suddenly the
limiting graph will become convergence
in the stretched type metric instead of
refailed touch metrics
foreign
[Music]
I felt like here I'm borrowing some
terminology from statistical physics I
don't know how accurate they are but I'm
saying that if the edges will definitely
be connected I will call them hard edges
if they will be connected with certain
probability in less than one I will call
them Bernoulli edges because whether I
connect them or not I follow up an only
sampling probability and then again for
Christians model it has both hard edges
and Bernoulli urgents and for this
adapted model it will only have
Bernoulli edges other it we only have
hard edges
and then
um I also made another
parameter transformation for a n to the
alpha I now named it n to the gamma log
n so the login parameter here is mainly
for technical convenience we can drop it
it will not affect the argument so then
gamma greater than or equal to 2 and the
camera lesson 2 will correspond to the
different regions or you can just say
gamma greater than two will become the
subcritical and the gamma lesson 2 will
become the super critical and then the
critical regime was well studied it's
and varies as n to the power to over
Alpha and we will show that
[Music]
um
like in the different parameter regimes
we see different phenomena and when it's
in the sub-critical regime usually we
will not see any graph it's always empty
and in the rare case that it's not empty
we will see exactly one Edge and then
controlling in the silver critical
regime we will see a limiting grapher
emerging in the stretched cut metric and
also we will see that the parameter
Alpha mysteriously disappears so there
is some universality under certain
reselling
all right so first the simulation
picture so this simulation picture was
done for different values of Alpha and
the gamma
and also uh for any cost ten thousand
okay and then uh one thing I wanted to
note is that so here I ordered the
vertices from
um according to their degree so it's
so here it's a degree from large to
small and we can see that this is like
um
this curve shows a degree distribution
in some sense and then for a larger
degree to smaller screen where this
seems to be like well over X
and we will justify that in a minute
and to study this model I group the
different vertices into two types of
vertices one called click rate types the
other follower vertex so in some sense
it goes back to Shivers type 1 type 2
and all these different types okay so
for treat vertices I just separate them
by the value x i greater than the square
root of a n and the follower vertices
less than or equal to that so in other
words all lit vertices will definitely
connect and the follower vertices we
only get connected to delete vertex but
not among themselves and this is a
picture showing what I mean here so
these are the click vertices and these
are the follower TC right just a simple
illustration all right and then you want
some straightforward calculations we can
do so expected value of the number of
edges will scale like this and and then
expected value of number of vertices
will stay like this so because this is
um by the toy example so all these
computations can be done rather easily
and then in the super oh sorry in the
sub critical regime
um because the
we can study the click vertices number
and then it varies as a binomial
distribution with this parameter
and we can check that the number of
Click vertices greater than or equal to
when the probability is the same as the
probability equal to one and then I
still like this and then it's always
going down to zeros only conditional
limit theorem is we're starting here and
there is a fine point here because just
that we have a complete vertex does not
exactly mean it's actually different
apps so it could be that the follower
vertices do not get connected to the
create vertices so in fact the
probability that we have a three two
vertex and follower vertex that's
connected to the delete vertex is
smaller than just having a treat for
that and then having one follower
exactly one follower vertex
has the same probability as having many
follower vertices and
[Music]
for this one particular click workout we
can have we cannot say have different
classes of follow-over pieces because
there is only one click vertex
and then
um so in the typical regime we will have
exactly two vertices and one treat
vertex and one follower vertex so I
tried to find a physical incubation for
that again like Charles and friend are
probably better experts and answering
these questions but like the
interpretation I had in mind was that
there's some energy pushing follower
vertices to create vertices and other
vertices to follow over vertices to get
connected to things in the graph and
then we only have certain energy to do
that in the subcritical regime so this
is the best we could do
foreign
so now let's finally move to this more
exciting super critical regime so to
study the phenomena in the super
critical regime
um it's more technical so what I did was
that uh so for each vertex I will
consider the number of vertices
connected to the advert types and this
will give me a height function so I will
only consider the height function for
the Reiki fees in the click and then for
zero lesson X less than equal to one is
denotes the number of vertices now that
connect you to the top x k and zero
trade vertices so K and 0 represents the
total number of Click vertices and by
varying at from 0 to 1 it tells me
exactly how many vertices are connected
to the click vertices and then it will
give me a curve so in particular hn of 1
is the number of followers of the leader
from the click and action of zero is
zero by convention so a channel when the
number of followers of the leader
because hm 1 means
um
the clip vertex with the largest value
so if it's a click vertex with the
largest value then
um if a follower vertex will get
connected to other delete word types it
will get connected to this leader so
this is an increasing function
and then the main theorem is around your
motion convergence result so
um showing this now let me first talk
about some implications of this serum
before we look at the details so
actually to derive the theorem the first
thing I did was I expected I calculated
the expected value of this hn of X and
also the variance of action of X and I
found that they both scale according to
the same spelling limit and then I was
like okay more things can be set here so
in some sense when we consider graph
limit Theory we say that
um being the limit the graph converges
to a limiting graphing that's like the
first order approximation so here if we
subtract the value the average value
from the actual value because it's a
random variable there are some still
higher order fluctuations over there and
this higher order fluctuation is
captured or captured by this Brony
emotions thing Hi and then
um when I got this result I thought it's
already pretty good because I've never
seen such degree
um fluctuation results anywhere else I
thought with long pay and he was like oh
you just need to make some twists here
and there here and there and then you
can go from FDD convergence to process
convergence in your restaurant topology
in your space cr01 so there are stronger
results we can say here
so before diving into the proofs what's
your main implication here so from this
FTD convergence we can see that in the
limit expected value of this height
function varies like this and then the
variance of the height function has the
same spelling and also explicit formula
like this and then because I'm ordering
the [ __ ] vertices with their value from
small to large it introduces a simple
transformation from the simulation
picture I showed you earlier so it's a
single transformation from ads going to
Y minus X so from here we can get
the boundary Trail we saw earlier would
be one flat list divided out by the
stalings and it's exactly 1 over X like
we saw in the simulations and this one
plus is because
um for this hnl of x height function
might remember we just denote this to be
the number of follower vertices that are
connected to the [ __ ] vertices so all
the click vertices are connected to
themselves so there is an actual one
plus thing here and then the scaling I
used here is also by this expected value
of the number of clicks and it will be
more apparent in a few minutes why use
this spelling
okay so uh
okay so further implications okay so
um
you can see that
um essentially this result is saying
that under this expected value of number
of clip scaling we will get a limiting
grapher and the limiting grapher will be
random free uh it's um x y less than or
equal to Y is one and then otherwise
it's zero so this feels very similar to
the stretched cut metric convergence we
talked about earlier for the stretched
and cardometric convergence it should be
stretching by the one Norm of this WN
and it's equal to this and here if we
have the log n Factor it has an extra
loading Factor so if we drop that lodium
factor it's exactly the stretch the cut
metric convergence and if we keep that
it's still very similar but then one is
on the boundary
all right so
for the last few minutes let me talk
about the proof of this so the idea of
the proof is that we are going to
introduce iib sequences of random
variables so one is according to whether
they are click vertices or follower
vertices we do them according to whether
the value is I name them different
numbers Y and then Y and Z and then the
Y vertices are the clinical vertices and
then all these so this part gives me the
different thresholds for well the
follower vertices will for between so by
different thresholds I just mean some
follower vertices will get connected to
all the delete vertices and some
follower vertices here that connected to
say only one click word that's
and then
[Music]
um
so and then for all the different X
values
we introduce this
uh the threshold function and then by
the threshold function we can uh right
rewrite the height function as a sum of
these Bernoulli random variables so and
then we will study the order statistics
of this
and then nephew Bernoulli
um
random memorables and then the proof is
quite technical it's several Pages using
convergence of quantile processes from
shorak so if you are interested in more
technical details happy to tell you more
later okay so and then
um a bit more details is that so the
proof technique is that we are going to
write this BMI of it and then subtract
the conditional expected value from that
you might have seen this already in
bathrooms talk earlier okay so and then
this part will give us the bronia motion
part and this difference will give us an
independent running Bridge part
foreign
okay so lastly
let me give some final remarks on why I
find this model interesting so first of
all this W of X Y limiting graph on it's
random free it does not depend on the
parameter Alpha and also it's not always
incapable so even though Christian's
paper studied like all those LP graph
phones and conversions
um this shows that there are more
generalized results so we don't
necessarily need to constrain ourselves
to LP graphers or the conversions and
also this W of XY
um it's however locally finite and
satisfied with convergence results
and then for
um so I checked the generic formulas
infection Roy and then the theoretical
results match pretty well in this
setting so in this setting I was used
using in Brownian stuff and then it's
very similar results under the Sterling
e k and zero so in their paper they
named this building as new
and then also certain technical
conditions of the model may be relapsed
here I'm saying that it's a hard Edge
model
well the vertex labels satisfy a uniform
distribution and so on it feels very
special but then many conditions can be
relaxed for example we don't necessarily
need to consider exponential
distribution it can be a distribution
it's readily very entail and then the
results will still follow but then more
generally seeing such
Brown emotion and also certain other
fluctuation in the limiting grapher
naturally people would want their life
does this hold more generally and then
um I thought with fonte and he told me
some intuitive guesses he said it's not
entirely sure about everything but he's
intuitive guesses are like for hard
edges we can extend the situation to
more General models we don't necessarily
need to have
um product exceeding a threshold it
could be some exceeding a threshold and
so on but if we actually go back to
Christian's model where there are hard
edges and balloon edges then maybe you
will not see such nice bronya Motion in
the limit because the white noise is
stronger there
yeah but many more questions we're
thinking about and also here I only
discussed the degree distribution I
could be like sub grafting CP or what do
you think yeah
um
okay so I consulted many references
while preparing this talk but these are
the main references I use
thank you
okay so we have time for a few questions
foreign
settings in your model where the average
degree converges and if so would you be
able to prove local convergence that's a
very good question so I mean like for
the average degree
I mean like I know the degree at every
vertex
every click where that's it's given by
this value
so like you have averaging results but
local conversions have never thought
about that that's a very interesting
question because the click vertices are
very rare right so the followers are
going to be the main contribution right
for the local events yeah that's exactly
right so the main number of your edges
will come from follower vertices getting
connected to create vertices but great
work you see themselves
um yeah they only contribute a small
part but I doubt that you're going to
have a local limit why
well I mean she doesn't have bounded
average degrees the way it's done right
because the integral so the degree is 1
over X so the integral of the one over X
is Divergent if that integer were finite
she would have bounded average degree
but she doesn't
so
um which is actually little related I
mean
as you pointed out you're sort of at the
boundary of the stretched cut metric
convergence and you're sort of also of
the boundary of some more General
Graphics so there are two versions as
not here no you are observed as uh
people observed the the graphics
convergencing you can formulate into
settings one is there's a graph on
Graphics right the graph one is integral
and then there's a version there's a
graph one is locally find it as you
pointed out but not necessarily
integrable and they're slightly
different so I I I wonder there's our
and she's just at the boundary of the
two of them because her thing is almost
educated and so I could imagine that you
could do some
tweaking trying to sort of forget well
the clicks will just have unbounded
degrees in her setting
yeah so in general you will not be able
to have a local limit when you have
followers that are mainly connected to
the click vertices if they click even if
you have very few click vertices but
they have growing degrees right because
then the one neighborhood is going to
have already vertices that have
unbounded degrees Yeah so then the only
way how you can fix this is by having
the majority of your followers not
having any degree and then you do have a
local limit well it's not very
interesting
um
other questions
okay well good so you get your logic oh
you have a question or you're clapping
okay let's thank you again
[Applause]